I'm following Alan Downey who I'm sure
was very entertaining and educational in
the general track I I'll do my best it's
tough act to follow but I am going to
tell you about this package we're
developing and uh I want to start by
acknowledging my my main collaborator Dr
yarden Cohen who has a a lab at The
wisman
Institute uh he is a
neuroscientist you can find him at all
these places and it's thanks in large
part to his support I've been able to
continue doing this development
work and so right title of the talk core
package for animal acoustic
communication research in Python just so
we're all on the same
page uh when I say core package I mean
something like astropy which is at the
core of a community of packages for
researchers uh in
astronomy and uh our community studies
how animals communicate with
sound a and the reason that I continue
to develop software for this community
is I think it gets it sort of the key
questions what makes us human and I hope
that even if you don't do this research
this is this is part of what will
interest you in it um sort of like I'm
showing you here in this cogram you know
we know that the the brain areas that
initiate sound production in all uh in
all vertebrates are conserved we know
that basically all animals communicate
with sound in some way even if they
produce those sounds in different ways
we also know that um the brain areas
responsible for for Learning and
controlling vocalizations are related
across all vertebrates so this and a
bunch of other reasons make us think
that we can answer these sort of key
questions about what it means to be
Human by studying how all animals
communicate with sound so we want to
know H how could speech possibly have
evolved it there's few behaviors that we
think are unique now to humans but the
one that's left standing is what I'm
doing right now speaking a language but
like I said basically all animals
communicate with sound um many animals
learn their vocalizations in some way uh
song birds for example and dolphins
learn uh their vocalizations in an
imitative fashion very similar to how we
learn speech so if we can understand how
they learn those vocalizations it it
sort of gets at this big question of
what makes us human and as other people
have proposed uh have pointed out this
research is truly interdisciplinary it
requires experti as ranging from
genomics to ecology to Neuroscience
everywhere in between which means that
uh it requires big team science these
diverse expertises working together to
try to answer these big questions and
that in turn means you're going to have
big data so you want to automate the
analyses using cuttingedge computational
methods such as deep learning also known
as neural networks uh and other people
have reviewed how these neural network
models are being used to study acoustic
communication and in bioacoustics more
broadly I'll I'll share all these slides
later on social so that you can click on
these links find out about all these
papers if you're really
interested uh and you might be like okay
that sounds cool but do we really need a
core package so I'm going to just point
out some related work because I think
that this is a community effort and I
want to acknowledge other people doing
related work and also I want to
underscore that I I think this is an
idea whose time has come so there's many
related python packages but just two
recent ones that are in a similar area
are panto from nilo Marino recalde and
Co from yukoh
fukuzawa but if you go to this
repository from Tessa Reinhard she's a
graduate student in the kitus lab there
bioacoustic software you'll see that
there's there's hundreds of different
libraries with different formats for
audio array data and annotations uh for
people working in bioacoustics and
studying acoustic Communication in
animals so I'll come back to this this
suggests it would be really nice it
would be really helpful if we had a core
package and you know we've developed
vocal P like I'll tell you in a second
because we felt like we needed something
like this for our own work our goals are
to give you a library that's General and
robust enough that a scientist coder
could use it to write a highlevel
analysis script that's readable and
reusable across research groups but a
research software engineer could also
use it to develop the backend for uh an
application such as a guey and in this
way we want to enable better
collaboration you know for this big team
science for scientists research software
engineers and all the rest of us that
are somewhere in
between and the way we do this the
features in vocal that I'm going to walk
you through in more detail later are
data types that are specific to The
Domain that work with a wide variety of
formats because again there are many we
give you classes for common steps in
workflows such as segmenting audio or
Computing spectrograms visualizations of
sound I'll show you that later and these
classes are designed for reproducibility
so that they they capture the parameters
that you use and you're able to save
those later as important metadata and
sort of the goal here is to allow a
scientist coder to work interactively in
the way we often do but then for free uh
once you figured out your analysis share
that data set for example as a database
without needing to know
SQL uh and then in this way sort of move
to as we say in software engineering to
deployment right more
easily and what makes this possible is
the Scientific Python stack since we're
here at Pi data Global of course want to
thank num Focus for supporting not just
making this conference possible but also
supporting development of all these
packages that we're relying on for vocal
p uh and to again to tell you about why
we felt like we needed this I'm going to
walk you through a case study of this
neural network model we developed
tweeting met tweeting net that automates
annotation of animal sounds and does so
in a way that avoids issues with
segmenting audio uh it's described in
this paper Coen atow that's in e life
where you can read all the Gory details
but basically what it does is it takes
in a spectrogram that's again an image
of sound and then for every time bin in
the spectrogram it predicts a label and
by doing some post-processing to the
sequence of labels you might know this
is called a frame classification model
we can post-process all those frame
labels and then get the annotations that
we actually want to build some
behavioral model of how the animals
communicating or using sound
right and typically these kinds of
annotations are are done manually with a
guey it's an incredibly timeconsuming
process this is a real candidate for
using neural networks to to automate
this and and just so you understand what
I'm talking about here this is sort of a
a schematic of one one of these goys
might look like where you have a
spectrogram in the top panel showing you
frequencies on the y- AIS and time on
the x- axis and then on the bottom
you have this trace of the energy in the
sound this this dash line is showing you
how you can threshold that the
horizontal dash line and all the The
Continuous time periods above that
threshold become the segments that an
expert will then annotate apply some set
of labels to that's appropriate for
their analysis for whatever model of
behavior they're trying to build right
so this is a a a bengalese finch that's
a song bird that's one of an individual
ual Bales finches song I'm showing you
here and we're just labeling the
individual syllables in the
song and so you need these sequences of
units for for building these models of
acoustic behavior and communication but
an issue is that off-the-shelf signal
processing algorithms often don't work
across all species so here's an example
for canaries where setting a threshold
to segment this syllable will over
segment uh this other syllable a and the
same bird song and then under segment
this other syllable C right so again
this is a case where neural network
models are actually useful right to
automate this so you can map directly
from the spectrogram to the annotations
without dealing with a more uh
parametric signal processing
model and just showing you really quick
four examples recently of of models that
were fit using annotations predicted by
tweeting net these are models of syntax
of motor learning of dialect in song
birds uh so this is useful but the point
I want to actually make here is what
we're finding is it's still too hard for
people to use our code so let's talk
about the code so tweeting net began
Life as a single Jupiter notebook
written in tensor flow uh we were trying
to be good computational scientists so
we developed a neural network framework
we call V we just presented this at
scipi there's a proceedings paper you
can check out please if you're
interested we have a version 1.0 out now
in Alpha where we switch to using
lightning and pytorch as a backend and
we're giving you better abstractions for
these models and the task and the data
sets uh but what we found after doing a
ton of work is that people would say oh
that's great but I have this specific
annotation format so I can't use it or I
have to like you know convert my
annotations to a format you're using so
we said fine we'll develop a library
just for dealing with annotation form
formats it's called cetta went through
review of Pi openai uh was published in
the Journal of Open Source software G I
gave a lightning talk at Pyon about this
uh about our experience submitting there
please check it out because pyop andai
is a great
organization uh and so again trying to
be good computational scientists we put
the paper out there's a separate project
that replicates the results in the paper
using these libraries we developed and
what we still found is people would ask
us for some functionality like I want to
visualize the outputs of the neural
network and we would say it's right
there in the code we shared it with you
but it turns out it was just still too
hard for them to read and uh even when
we showed it to them it was hard for
them to adapt to their specific data so
this brings me back to this point about
there's just many different formats for
audio array data annotations that are
used uh to study animal communication
and in BIO Acoustics more broadly as
Tessa uh show shows in this this great
resource with all these tools that
people are
developing and so you know bringing it
up a level
again there's sort of two ways of
working there's goys which often don't
capture all the parameters or steps in
analysis the way they're developed now
or they they might be developed in a
propri proprietary language there's
there's other issues there that you're
probably familiar with analysis scripts
and libraries can sort of uh address
some of those issues but because of all
the different formats I just told you
about they often deal with really
low-level details and so that means the
data set preparation and the analysis
will be tightly coupled to those formats
meaning that scripts are hard to read
and hard for other groups to reuse and
libraries similarly are harder for a
user to configure because they need to
be thinking about these low-level
details and so here's from a proceedings
paper we uh presented on vocal just
showing you this sort of toy example of
a a script that I might write when I'm
figuring out my analysis and what will
happen is I have some key parameter that
I accidentally hide as a default in some
helper
function and I'll often end up with this
proliferation of variables because I
don't have a data types that are
specific to my domain so I need to track
the uh sampling rate along with the data
for audio I have to pass that to another
function where I'm going to get back not
just the spectrogram but the vectors of
frequencies and times so now I'm
Shuffling all these variables around
between between functions it gets really
verbose so just using data types alone
like I show in the second snippet in the
paper can make the code more succinct
this leads me into the the features in
vocal so so we have data types specific
to The Domain such as an audio class
here I'm using this helper function
paths from dur to just get all the wave
files from a directory and then in a
list comprehension here here I load them
using the read method of this audio data
type and then I have encapsulated in a
single class instance the data along
with the sample rate and the channels as
attributes so I no longer need to carry
those around as separate
variables and I also have path like the
file that metadata such as the path so
that I'm tracking that and can use it to
build a data set
later and uh sort of glossing over some
of the
details uh for people that aren't in
this domain we we do something similar
for a spectrogram so that again you have
all those uh the frequencies and the
times as attributes instead of separate
vectors you can uh read and write them
to a file so if they're really expensive
to to compute which they often are for
high sampling rate data then you only
have to do that
once we give you functionality with
matlb to plot and inspect those we have
an annotation data type that uses cetta
under the hood and again saves the pad
so that you can use that when building
data sets later and you can uh again
using M plot lib plot the spectogram
along with the annotations so you can
see what what you're
annotating and then we get to the the
classes that we have for uh different
steps and workflows for segmenting audio
into these sequences of units for these
different analyses we do we provide a
single class and then everything else is
very functional so you you have a
function that does the segmenting you
give that to the class as a callback
along with the parameters that you
explicitly declare so this is sort of
making it clearer in your scripts these
are the parameters that I use they don't
get hidden in a helper
function and and additionally this
callback lets you reuse existing code in
your lab right so so this is a way to
take existing code Labs have spent a lot
of time developing and just make it more
readable without forcing them to use you
know some different uh and switch to an
entirely different Library we have the
same thing for a
spectrogram generation we parallelize
all this with dask thank you dask for
making this trivial can use all the uh
threads on your CPU use all the nodes in
your cluster thanks to
dask uh and then finally with the
sequences you get out you can then use a
separate class the sequence data set
class which as I alluded to before for
free lets you just save this as a a
sqlite uh database so this is a single
file database format built into pytho
built into python it's archival
recommended by the Library of Congress
so you don't have to have like
administrator privileges to install
MySQL or something you just get this
database you can share as a single file
with your
collaborators okay and you might be
saying that all sounds great but let me
see you actually using it so let me talk
a little bit about results so we just
presented at the society for
Neuroscience meting meeting this poster
on benchmarking different neural network
models and there's basically two
families of these frame classification
models for uh automating segmentation
and annotation of animal sounds there's
recurrent neural networks like tweeting
NES and there's temporal convolutional
networks like in this other paper from
steinfath at Al again I I'll share links
to all this
later and we did some experiments to
compare these there's a lot of detail
here I'm committing the academic sin of
recycling uh very complicated figures
the main thing I want you to take away
here is that uh all of these models use
a fixed size spectrogram window when we
train them and when we run inference to
get these
predictions and then like I told you
before we do some postprocessing on the
predicted label for every frame to
recover these segments with onset times
offset times and labels and we can do
some cleanups there that often really
help performance
and so what we saw is that if you really
increase that window size it actually
increases the performance there's a
direct relationship there and I'm
showing you here with one metric the
character error rate uh basically that
is an edit distance that is computed at
the level of the labels for the segments
and you try to uh recover the ground
truth labels from the predicted labels
by making edits so the more edits the
greater the distance
and what you can see here is for all
these three models we're looking at uh
when you compare the blue bar with the
orange bar going from a window size of
176 to a window size of 2,000 you get a
big drop in the character error ratees
and that holds true even after you do
this post-processing with the cleanups
that really reduces the character error
rate which also shows you there's a lot
more that these these networks could
learn so to say but uh this this window
size really matters and then using the
metrics we've added to vocal PI from
music information retrieval for
segmentation we're able to look at what
we haven't looked at before which is how
well these models segment uh and
basically the way this works is you look
for the boundaries the onset and offset
times and then within a window some
tolerance of like 10 milliseconds say
you ask if there's a predicted boundary
and you compute these standard
information retrieval metrics like
Precision which is true positives over
true positives plus false posit
positives and you you see a similar
story where a bigger window again gives
you a higher Precision here you know we
want a higher Precision not
lower the story is a little less clear
when you look at recall uh the the TCN
have a higher recall but we think that
this is because they they tend to over
segment so so one way you can get higher
recall is just by predicting a boundary
at every time bin you would of course
have a very low Precision then uh but
this is our understanding of what's
going on here and this sort of shows you
why these metrics aren't perfect and we
might need something else but but still
we we have these metrics now that tell
us how we're doing with segmentation
this gave us the Insight that we could
modify the loss function used to train
the neural network I don't have time to
go into the math of that we basically
add an additional ter to this loss
function and it it reduces this over
segmentation both for TCN and the the
recurrent neural
network and so now finally going into
some work in progress and bringing it
back you know away from neural network
engineering more to uh how animals
communicate with sound I told you that
song birds similar to humans learn their
song by imitation and a long-standing
question is like how how do we measure
that so this seminal method from ofer
chernovsky and his
collaborators uh you know derived a way
to compute similarity you essentially
get this Matrix of similarity scores
find these bounding boxes that you can
that you can use to uh get a single
number
out uh and ofer you know heroically
developed an entire
application uh and gave it to labs in
the Dark Ages before we had GitHub then
later translated it to mat lab again
acknowledging other people's work Paul
eof in a masteris thesis translated a
lot of this to Python and teres cook
who's in the Todd Roberts lab more
recently in her Aven package has done a
lot of work to make it so that that you
uh she's implemented the multi-taper
spectral processing that you need to get
these um features that you use to do the
similarity analysis and basically uh I
knew we needed a feature module in vocal
I've added one for the features for sat
i' I've done a little bit to vectorize
the feature computation a little bit
more and uh additionally we'll be adding
more features because we know that this
is used more broadly in studies of
acoustic communication you know pointing
to Frederick Ten's lab who has this
package sound Sig has a big Focus On
These predefined acoustic features Julie
Ellie who developed a lot of that and is
now working in Michael yarts of lab to
study bats has really pioneered this
kind of of
analysis so so work in progress hoping
to get that merged today um and then
going to the road map you know our
vision is to have vocal pie at the core
of this community of package for
researchers that are studying acoustic
communication uh we're thankful that we
already have many contributors thanks to
all of you uh we have a growing Forum
forum.org
uh I'd love it if you st the
repositories because of course that's
how you know that software is good join
the Forum we'd love contributions we uh
to the code and in any other way we
value all contributions uh we'd love it
if you attend our development meetings
uh you can find us again here and you
can find me at all of these places so I
think I managed to finish on time I'll
go ahead and stop sharing and see if we
have any
questions